you need to give away your your
citizenship today I'm taking the US
citizenship test I'm not sure if I'm
gonna pass and I sold my soul to AP US
history for two years so I'm really
hoping that I pass so I got naturalized
on September 24th 2015 I came from
Taiwan I moved here when I was about 12
from India I became an American citizen
in April 15 last year and I am
originally from the Dominican Republic
so when you took the test like you
couldn't you know answer on paper this
is not an open book question you should
have to answer the question right there
right there
business I think this test is easy I
took this test and I passed with very
good grades I did grow up taking
American history but I definitely did
like fresh up on things before I went
because I wanted to make sure I passed I
think the test is easy I think you do
well on this I think I know some about
American history and government I think
I know a good amount I'm not gonna say
I'm an expert good luck thanks I'm gonna
need it what is the name of the Speaker
of the House of Representatives now it's
a guy that I don't like but some people
think it's cute I don't know any
good-looking guys in the White House is
that Mitch McConnell Paul Ryan I don't
know that is name to national us
holidays
Independence Day Martin Luther King jr.
Day Christmas and hoeing how definitely
not even what was the Declaration of
Independence adopted I'm like scared
because I know like the general numbers
for this I know there are a ton of odd
numbers in it and it's four digits July
4th so yeah 10 feets every music 7500
the House of Representatives has how
many voting members I feel like I know
this classes are fog I'm getting nervous
300 that times a million is how much
money I want my bank account 500 all
right I'm gonna say 50 is it going to be
like 435 are you kidding me
let's go there great i this many people
though and yeah we have who is the Chief
Justice of the United States now Chief
Justice soda - they're probably like old
and white and male it's John Roberts I
wouldn't have known them so I'm not
upset just tell me on a very very white
a very white named Bob Jones how many US
senators are there I'm gonna say 50 on
this one 50 - no way because it's - per
state yes 50 states yes crap who was
president during World War one wait
actually due to Roosevelt's so I guess
Roosevelt did you know this yes you got
it right no uh which one Franklin no it
was not bad one it was Teddy no no no
Woodrow Wilson yeah yeah I was good
because I was a history question the
rest are like current events questions
which I steer so clear of you passed a
America is Donald Trump gonna see this
am I gonna be deported the questions
that you got wrong were about the
government and I thought that everyone
knew about the government I guess not I
always joke about how I know more
American history than natural yeah I
can't get mad
most of questions I got wrong were about
people who are in the government and I'm
not as familiar they probably should be
with that this is my country I live here
I don't judge myself for missing some of
the very current questions because I
think my like like a lot of people I'm
trying to pretend politics and don't
exist right now when I took it I thought
it was easy but only it was easy because
I studied a lot I'm guess I don't have
to study up on my US history then I'm
gonna try to be more open to
understanding and learning about who's
running our country you get to know a
lot to get into America and the
restrictions are getting harder and
harder
I took my citizenship for granted today
[Music]